how to promote your art business if
you're an artist you're trying to get
out there trying to get known you want
people to buy your stuff you've got to
get out there and promote yourself but
how do you do it because most artists do
a really bad job of promoting themselves
this came a question that came in from
one of my readers Alison she's an artist
and the summarizer with this huge long
email but the samurai she's feeling the
pain she's tried a lot of things
everything she can think of she doesn't
have a back-up plan this has to work for
her there's no plan B she doesn't have
an idea for a software app or something
else to make this business has to work
and there doesn't seem to be a plan in
place from any money out there who can
give her guidance on what to do so
Alison I'm gonna give it my best shot
I've got a soft spot in my heart for
artists because I love the work that you
create I've invested in the salsa dance
school here in Toronto that's become one
of the biggest in the world over a few
years and that's been exciting and I
want to see artists flourish the first
part is understanding you've got to do
this yourself and Alison is on board she
knows she's got to do this herself but
for you where the artist this is on you
it's not just you sitting in a studio
creating work you've got to get out
there and talk about what you're doing
and the good news is has never been more
fun and more easy to do it than today
and more fun you might think Evan you're
crazy we're fun it's not fun that's work
I don't want to do that I just want to
create but the thing is I want you to
build a movement okay I want people to
associate your name with a word with a
feeling something powerful and when
people are connecting with you they're
writing in the share how your work
inspired them to do something when
people write to you and say how much
you've changed their lives or open their
perspective that makes you feel good
that makes you want to keep going it
makes you it gives you strength to know
that you're not alone that this is what
saved me when I started making these
videos I was just talking to myself
nobody was watching and and I got
discouraged but what kept me going what
keeps me going is you guys you guys
watch these videos you keep me going
because you leave comments you tell me
you like it you tell me I help inspire
you that gets me excited to keep going
with my business so I wasn't
artists you need to start getting out
there promoting your stuff so people
know about it and can talk about you and
tell you how much they love your work I
keep you inspired now how do you do that
okay step one the first thing you need
to figure out is what do you stand for
come up with with something this comes
out with your art as an artist this
should be easier for you than most
people because your art Allison here is
a painter your art makes people feel
something every business should make a
customer feel something you have a leg
up as an artist because your art that's
what it's all about if your art is not
making people feel something then you're
not doing a good job you have to make
people feel through your art so I know
you understand this what are you trying
to make people feel is it you make them
feel calm you can feel angry we can feel
depressed you can feel happy you make
them feel encouraged inspired what is it
what comes across through your art help
explain that and then stand for that so
what I want you to do is think about
your social media channels okay I want
you to open up a Twitter account a
Facebook account and a blog and I want
you to share what this one word is it
encapsulates what you do what is it what
do you stand for what do you want people
to feel when they look at your art it's
not just looking at something beautiful
they should feel something that's real
art right that's what gets people
excited and inspired they look at art
and they feel something so what do you
want people to feel about your art and
start sharing that so be known as the
artist who stands for this who's
creating a movement around this feeling
what is that
nobody does this this is your chance to
stand out alongside sharing your art
your painting so that takes a long time
I want you to explain your art tell me
why you created this tell me what
inspired you to create this painting
what made you want to do this explain it
in detail because a lot of people can't
understand art so break it down for me
then I want you to also share things
that are that are not related to your
actual art but that still inspire you so
if you're all about calm for example
okay you're all about calm I want you to
share your
choose your paintings that are about
calm I want you to share how you've made
that calm painting all the thought that
went behind it and then I want you to
share other things quotes pictures
passages books that are related to calm
that inspire you because what I want you
to do is be at the head of this calm
movement that you're creating let's take
another one so you're doing empowerment
okay I've never seen your painting so I
don't know what they're all about but
say it's empowerment okay you want
people to look at your paintings and
feel empowered
so empowerment's your word everything
that you spread on social media is going
to be about empowerment it's going to be
your paintings it's going to be how you
did it it's going to be quotes that
inspire you it's going to be books that
inspire you
so you other people who paint or who
talk about empowerment that you're going
to put up why not put one of your
paintings with a quote by melting by
Nelson Mandela on the front and share
that you want people to share that and
when people will spread the message for
you and they'll see that powerful quote
and the look at the paint and say who
made that painting and partner up with
people who believe in the same thing if
your paintings were all about believe
partner with me because I'm all about
belief I love sharing stuff that's about
belief I would share your art if your
painting was about believe and you came
to me I would share it because we're
automatically on the same page so
whatever you stand for connect with
those people who believe the same thing
and they'll help you share it here's an
example okay I recently commissioned an
artist to do some artwork for me I've
created a new series of guides and one
of the guides is on thinking big
I want entrenar think bigger to not just
settle for these little deals but go
after bigger deals and believe in
themselves so I wanted an artist to
create a beautiful painting that would
go across the top of the page with
digital art that encapsulated the
thought process the feeling of thinking
big and I had a heck of a time finding
an artist to do it imagine so I'm typing
in like thinking big artist you're
searching for this stuff nothing comes
up this is your chance people are
looking for this stuff people who want
to come
an artist for certain feeling does it
trying to get why do i why am i
commissioned an artist because I want a
feeling that's why people are going to
hire you they want a feeling to come
across if you're doing it for a
boardroom if you're doing it for some
software program if you're doing it for
somebody's home they want a feeling
what's that feeling people are searching
for this they're looking for you I was
looking for an artist that would help me
create something around thinking big
maybe that's you but artists do not do a
good job of promoting themselves so that
could be you and you were lying there's
it's hard okay because you're creating
this stuff you're creating all this
great content around this movement
you're building but at the start nothing
happens right at the start of believe
for me nothing that was just me it was
only me I was talking to myself but
slowly people picked up on it because it
was powerful because you can feel the
passion that comes across everything I'm
sharing and you can do videos or not it
doesn't matter but what you're putting
out is passionate around that keyword
that you believe in so what is it share
it with me because people are searching
for that and they will contact you and
say I love everything you're doing I
would love for you to create a painting
for me around this theme here's my
vision and they'll hire you and it may
seem not concrete enough for you it may
seem like I've tried that and it's not
working social media doesn't work I've
landed a ton of great business from
social media but only once I started to
narrow my focus once I started talking
about believe if you look at my channel
I have videos about belief I have
pictures about belief I've my own quotes
about belief
I have other famous entrepreneur quotes
about believe I have inspiring memes
that are going out about believe
everything is about belief if you love
believe if you believe in believe you'll
love my channel if you don't then you
won't but I stopped trying to be
everything to everybody and started
sharing my own stuff and other people's
stuff that I found inspiring around
belief you got to do the same thing for
yourself
create that calendar where you're
sharing your own art your own quotes
your own thought process but also
bringing in other people and you're
building a movement here something
people will attract and share they're
not just going to share your painting in
isolation I hope that makes sense you
know if you want to create this channel
and post a few things on it let me know
what you're standing for send it to me
and I'll review it because it's so
important and it'll make you feel good
I'll make you feel like you're doing
something beyond yourself you're not
just painting for yourself anymore
you'll have an audience a community it's
something powerful you're trying to
impact in the world that'll drive you
believe for those are watching like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes you want to do more and
I'd love to hear from you if you have a
question you want me to go in more
detail here about this topic let me know
below you want something else for your
business leave it in the comments I'll
make a video response thank you so much
and I'll see you soon